Someone with skin cancer, would you still recommend that it's beneficial to get some short-time daily?
A beneficial son on the spots on the skin cancer spots of course not birdie. I have heard that for natural doctors that it can be
beneficial, but dermatologists almost forbid people to get out of the sun and recommend using daily sunscreen
for staying inside
so i don't think the sun causes cancer so the sun does not cause cancer it's not just what i think it
just doesn't however sun burns can cause cancer so a bird so the sun shines you're getting
radiation from the sun right so not all radiation is bad it's excess radiation that causes damage to
cells that can then lead to cancer whether you're getting multiple x-rays at a doctor's office
you're getting radiation therapy let's say for breast cancer there's many people that get radiation
therapy on soft tissue post um lumpectomy on breast cancer and then several years later they end up
with a melanoma at that site well because that radiation damage the skin just as much as you
went out and you were a sun baiter addicted to sun baited and you burned often it's the birdie it's
that damaged skin that causes that could lead to cancer so going out and getting some sun is the right
thing to do now i know different people have different skin types and um i personally have the type of
skin i never have ever worn sun uh uh screed ever i just don't burn i mean i will if i go out and
you know if i go to floor not so maybe the Minnesota and Wisconsin go out to Florida in
January and you haven't been out in the sun for three months and i go out and let myself be scorched
but if you were happy protect yourself that's the idea but i just don't burn easy
all summer long i am outside never do i rarely ever burn other people have more scandinavian
skin type that they just burn really easy so they have to be careful now if you're going to use a
sunscreen i use a natural sunscreen the sunscreens that are out there on the market uh that you'd buy
in the grocery store or at the at Target or something are far more cancer-causing than their cancer
preventative so they cheer you're getting a natural sunscreen we just started carrying some
products a natural sunscreen that are really good i haven't used them because i don't use sunscreen
but i kids have used them we've had a lot of really good feedback from people who have purchased them